There is a whole lot to
know about Android testing.
Honestly, we could, and
probably should, make an entire
course on how to do it well.
Let's just look into
how to run tests and
when to use unit tests
versus connected tests.
We've defined a super simple
project with this class Echo.
It has a method that just returns
whatever you put into it.
It also has another version
of Echo where it first
logs whatever you input and
then returns it.
We've also added a product
flavor to this project.
In the paid folder, we've got
paid Echo which does essentially
the same thing but for
collections instead of single objects.
So we have this collection echo that
echos back whatever you put in.
And then this version of echo that
first logs each item that you put in.
So, we have defined some
tests in the test directory.
These are JUnit tests and so we just
verify that echo is in fact behaving how
we expect and that the logging version
of echo is behaving how we expect.
To test the paid flavor,
in the testPaid folder,
we have another pair of
extremely simple JUnit tests
that just verify that the echo of
the collection works as expected.
And that the echoing of the collection
with logging works as expected.
All of this code is in
the course repository, so
you can get a closer look there.
If we open up the Gradle pane,
and run the check task.
Let's see what happens
when we run these tests.
Uh-oh, we have failing tests.
We can check out the report at this
file path to see what went wrong.
So here we are at app> build > reports
> tests > freeDebug > Index.html.
And here's our report
of what went wrong.
Let's see Method i in
android.util.log not mocked.
So I think I know what's
going wrong here.
We tried to use the Android
logger from a unit test.
Now, the Android framework doesn't exist
when we're running unit tests since
those are being run
on the local machine.
If we want to test something that
is accessing the Android framework,
we have to run those on the device.
Let's move those into connected
tests instead of unit tests.
So we'll comment out the tests that
require the Android framework,
comment this one out too, and
now we'll added our connected to
test to the Android test directory.
Note that this is an Android test
case now instead of a JUnit test, and
we can add our paid tests to
the Android test paid directory.
Now if we open up the Gradle pane, and
run connected check, and there we go.
The tests that require accessing
the Android framework will run
on the device, where the Android
framework is available.
And they all pass.